kommando zurück die bundeskanzlerin
bittet die bürger öffentlich um
verzeihung die oster ruhe war ein fehler
und sei so nicht umsetzbar
was am montag mit den
ministerpräsidenten entschieden wurde
dafür übernimmt merkel die alleinige
verantwortung
ein tiefpunkt im kampf gegen korona und
die opposition bringt die
vertrauensfrage ins spiel
aber auch in der union wächst die unruhe
denn in den umfragen schwindet die
zustimmung zur politik von cdu/csu und
einen kanzlerkandidaten und gibt es hier
auch noch nicht es sind unruhige zeiten
für das land und auch für die
christdemokraten merkel unter druck wer
führt die union aus der krise unser
thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde ein fehler muss als fehler
benannt werden und vor allem muss er
korrigiert werden und ermöglicht hat
dass noch rechtzeitig zu geschehen
gleichwohl weiß ich natürlich dass
dieser gesamte vorgang zusätzliche
verunsicherung auslöst das bedauere ich
zutiefst und dafür bitte ich alle
bürgerinnen und bürger um verzeihung
ein ungewöhnlicher auftritt der
bundeskanzlerin heute mittag im
kanzleramt und dann auch noch im
bundestag herzlich willkommen zur
phoenix runde ich darf meine gäste
vorstellen
jaana ehmcke ist bei uns seit 2013 ist
sie für die cdu im bundestag sie ist
stellvertretendes mit geld verdiene
vorsitzende nicht mitglied stefan riebel
vorsitzende der mittelstands union und
bei der kandidatensuche war sie
unterstützerin von friedrich merz
herzlich willkommen georg streiter
begrüße ich ganz herzlich aber von 2011
bis 2018 stellvertretende
regierungssprecher davor war er auch mal
redakteur bei der bild zeitung und ist
jetzt freier autor und blogger und
herzlich willkommen zugeschaltet aus
münchen anna klaus sie ist bayern
korrespondentin des spiegel und autor in
der biografie söder die andere biografie
und herzlich willkommen moritz küper er
ist korrespondent für den
deutschlandfunk in nordrhein westfalen
und hat ein buch über armin laschet
geschrieben der macht menschliche
herzlich willkommen herr körper frau
schimke das war ein ungewöhnlicher
auftritt der kanzlerin heute mittag wo
sie ganz klar einen fehler eingeräumt
hat und auch gesagt hat sie trägt
alleine die verantwortung für die oster
ruhe für diesen ruhetag der so nicht
umsetzbar ist
daraufhin hat die opposition direkt die
vertrauensfrage ins spiel gebracht hat
gesagt eigentlich müsste die kanzlerin
vielleicht mal fragen ob sie noch das
vertrauen genießt genießt sie noch ihr
vertrauen
das tut sie in jedem fall und ich halte
die geste die unsere kanzlerin uns heute
gegenüber gezeigt hat für eine sehr
große geste eine wirklich sehr starke
geste
ich glaube allerdings auch dass jetzt
nicht die zeit ist auch so einer
situation politischen profit zu schlagen
so wie es die opposition im moment tut
ich glaube es kommt jetzt darauf an zu
schauen wie kommen wir weiterhin durch
diese corona krise mit
gut erfolgreich und vor allen dingen
schnell unter einbezug des parlaments
das ist eine ganz entscheidende
forderung von uns aber auch unter
mitnahme natürlich der bevölkerung
es gab viel respekt für diese für diese
geste von ihm den respekt zollen sie
hier auch es gab aber vorher auch jede
menge ärger in der unionsfraktion
nämlich über diese entscheidungen vom
montag nach schildern sie doch mal ein
bisschen den unmut in der fraktion wir
als abgeordnete sind nah bei den
menschen vor ort wie bekommen alles was
die bundesregierung tut unmittelbar
gespiegelt und ich persönlich habe immer
kritisiert dass das parlament die
verantwortung aus der hand gegeben hat
und die regierung in dieser pandemie
sozusagen vollständig das handeln und
das entscheiden überlässt und ich finde
es wichtig dass das parlament weiterhin
diese so gravierenden entscheidungen in
diese freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen
involviert ist und deswegen ist
natürlich die kritik auch in unseren
reihen sehr sehr groß wir merken die
stimmung kippt vor ort wir haben eine
politische spaltung in diesem land das
erleben wir ganz unmittelbar
wir können den menschen auch selbst die
maßnahmen nicht in voller gänze mehr
erklären
und das führt natürlich auch zu ärgern
der fraktion und ich finde es gut dass
die regierung sich dem angenommen hat
welchen anteil spielt hinter die
kanzlerin weil weber ist ja immer
diejenige die gesagt hat wir müssen das
eigentlich schärfere maßnahmen habe ja
es ist natürlich sehr verkürzt zu sagen
nur die kanzlerin trägt die alleinige
verantwortung ich kann es nachvollziehen
dass sie das jetzt getan hat dass sie da
sich hingestellt hat gesagt hat ich
trage die alleinige verantwortung aber
sind wir mal ehrlich das was wir erleben
in dieser corona krise seit längerem
grenzt schon an ein system versagen und
das ist nicht nur das kanzleramt das ist
die bundesregierung das sind die
ministerpräsidenten der länder ja
sozusagen alle die in der exekutive
entscheiden und handeln
und deswegen ist der druck vonseiten des
parlaments auch so groß wohlgemerkt auch
aus der opposition
er streitet das waren klare worte von
der kanzlerin für diese vier respekt
bekommen hat aus der sicht des
ehemaligen regierungssprechers war das
jetzt so die die richtige flucht nach
vorne in einer krise die richtige
krisenkommunikation
ich glaube ich hat das einzig richtige
gemacht sie hat erkannt dass das
eine eine totgeburt war von anfang an
also entweder mache ich das land zu oder
ich mache es auf aber jetzt mit außen
mit grünen donnerstag außer samstag
das konnte man wirklich kaum ernsthaft
erzählen und das hätte man aber auch
schon montagabend wissen kann ich hätte
immer noch wohnt abend wissen können wir
als auch völlig schleierhaft wie man auf
so eine idee kommen konnte
aber da treffen sich halt immer
mutlosigkeit und
ratlosigkeit also ich meine in wahrheit
gibt es ja immer nur zwei alternativen
die eine ist wir machen das ganze land
mal zu so für drei wochen also oder für
10 tage wie diese intelligenz sowie die
ansteckung zeit ist oder und macht ganz
auf beides ist schwer zu begründen und
deshalb muss man einen mittelweg finden
so und dann wenn man wenn dann 16
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidenten und die kanzlerin
zusammensetzen
die leben ja auch von zustimmung das
heißt wir wollen ja alle außer der
kanzlerin aber sie wollen ja alle
wiedergewählt werden oder sie die wähler
nicht verschrecken und so aus lauter
angst einig man sich halt auf den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner und ja
diese unruhe die war halt einfach das
war einfach falsch und das hat sie sehr
schnell erkannt ich meine manchmal
dauern solche kenntnisse länger aber sie
hat ja vorher auch noch mal mit dem
ministerpräsidenten zusammen gesessen
vielleicht hören wir ganz kurz bevor wir
direkt nach in münchen und düsseldorf
gehen oder köln ist jetzt der vorsitz in
köln schauen wir mal wie die
ministerpräsidenten dann reagiert haben
nach dieser entschuldigung oder doch der
der verantwortung die die kanzlerin auf
sich genommen hat hören wir mal kurz
rein was der ministerpräsident aus
bayern markus söder dann hat mittag
gesagt hat ich habe großen respekt vor
der entscheidung und ehrlicherweise auch
großen respekt vorm verhalten der
kanzlerin
aber es ist nicht ihre alleinige
verantwortung
es haben alle ministerpräsidenten
entschieden ich war genauso dabei wie
alle anderen und deswegen glaube ich ist
es auch notwendig dass sich alle dann
dafür entschuldigen und es bedauern
ja also auch eine entschuldigung von
herrn söder frau klaus wie empfinden sie
da herrn söder der ja an der
pressekonferenz nach diesem
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz cover das
team vorsicht hat gewonnen und auch noch
mal klar gesagt hat wie wichtig es ist
dass es zum beispiel auch die soester
ruhe gibt ja das team vorsicht und
umsicht wir immer so schön sagt hat sich
durchgesetzt also eher und die kanzlerin
und deswegen ist es auch in der tat nur
anständig dass er jetzt nicht die
kanzlerin allein den kopf hinhalten
lässt sondern quasi sein kopf mit
anbietet gleichzeitig hat es ihm die
kanzlerin jetzt natürlich extrem einfach
gemacht dass sie vorangeht und und sagt
mea culpa ich bin schuld aber in der tat
also markus söder hätte glaube ich diese
ostereier auch sehr gerne umgesetzt also
er wird sich jetzt
er wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
maßnahmen überlegen wie er jetzt auf
eigene faust für ruhe in bayern sorgen
kann denn in der tat was was ist denn
jetzt stand der dinge es kann ja jetzt
nicht sein dass alle menschen nach
mallorca fliegen in den nächsten wochen
also das lka hat ja gerade gestern
gesagt wir steuern jetzt auf instanzen
von 300 zu nach ostern und infizierten
zahlen von über 40.000 dieses was da
reiner haseloff getwittert hat vor
kurz vor der pk und bodo ramelow dann
noch 26 fachamt infiziert hat also das
kann es ja nicht sein dass ich jetzt mal
die kanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten auf ein ratloses
einigen also eigentlich keine deutliche
führungsqualität was die korona krise
betrifft herrkoerper wie sehen sie es
denn auch aus seiten aus sicht von
nordrhein westfalen wie da gab es ja
immer dieses hin und her laschet söder
wer ist da stärker wer bremst wer geht
nach vorne jetzt diese geschichte der
den dieser auftritt der kanzlerin heute
ist das was man sagen kann das passt
auch zu armin laschet das hätte er
eigentlich auch genau so auf seine kappe
nehmen können
na ja das ist ja versucht er ist ja
ähnliche worte gefunden wie markus söder
landtag gesprochen man das auch gesagt
selbstkritik geübt an dieser stelle
letztendlich bleibt ihm dabei auf ein
anderes über die kanzlerin hat indirekt
durch diese entschuldigung bei ihnen
jetzt wieder die reihenfolge in der
union hergestellt markus söder auch an
die nation wissen sich hinterher ein
rein darstellt sucht ja ohnehin seine
rolle gerade als cdu-chef wer es auf der
natürlich ministerpräsidenten noch war
das fahren aber er möchte ja auch
kanzlerkandidat und kanzler werden
musste haben die führungsqualitäten
beweisen allerdings das ganze parallel
ist die bundeskanzlerin momentan noch
und das ist eine sehr schwierige
situation für ihn
in der eher so dass man einfach immer
noch seine rolle es ruft er hat ja auch
anders
markus söder nicht das privileg in
diesen kleineren unten in berlin wenn
diese apps zusammen kommen dabei zu
setzen insofern versuchte da irgendwie
eine art sichtbarkeit zurückkommen
versucht sich die rolle des koordinators
der cdu dazu geben aber ganz glücklich
war dass mit dieser regierungsform
rückwärts jetzt sicherlich und er hat
dann heute auch noch mal im landtag
gesagt dass es so eigentlich nicht
weitergeht hören wir da auch mal kurz
rein hören wir uns an armin laschet
heute im landtag nrw
ich wollte mal darauf aufmerksam machen
dass wir unsere methoden der governance
verändern müssen diese ministerpräsident
konferenz hat die menschen enttäuscht
wenn man davon 14 uhr sitzt bis 3 uhr
nachts und verhandelt stunde lang nur in
kleinen gruppen und deshalb wollte das
nennt man selbst kritik eines der dabei
war
wir können so nicht weitermachen ja auch
klare worte wir können so nicht
weitermachen
frau schimke das ist ja eigentlich eine
brannten bankrotterklärung das war dass
die kanzlerin sagt sie muss sich
entschuldigen so das sagt auch wir haben
das gemacht er sagt wir können so nicht
weitermachen das ist zeigt doch
eigentlich dass das alles nicht mehr so
funktioniert in der tat sollen bürger
der vertrauen haben richtig in der tat
das problem ist ja nicht jetzt erst mit
dieser ministerpräsidenten runde
entstanden
wir haben es seit längerem mit mit
enormen demonstrationen in diesem land
zu tun wir abgeordnete werden
bombardiert mit e mails mit briefen mit
rückfragen aus der mitgliedschaft aus
der wählerschaft da hat sich etwas
aufgebaut und insofern ich finde das ist
ein starker auftritt von armin laschet
heute im landtag in nordrhein-westfalen
und ich würde mir wünschen so was öfter
zu hören aber was folgt dann daraus was
daraus folgen muss ist ein kurswechsel
das heißt einfach mal vielleicht auch
mal andere wissenschaftliche meinungen
zuzulassen es ist es ist doch was ich
kann mich doch nicht nur mit dem rk ii
zusammensetzen ich kann mich doch nicht
nur mit einem kleinen teil von wissen
scheint dem in dieser frage zusammen wir
möchten sie sich dann zusammensetzen mit
anderen mann mit anderen meinungsbildung
mit an mit vertretern anderer
wissenschaftlicher meinungen in dieser
frage denn hier geht es doch um einen
abwägungsprozess die geht es doch nicht
nur darum eine linie hat durchzusetzen
ist
darum auch die bevölkerung mitzunehmen
und es gibt gerade in fragen der korona
politik und gerade in fragen was ist mit
dem virus was ist mit der mutation wie
gehen wir damit um was ist ein richtiges
kräfteverhältnis durchaus auch andere
akzeptierte meinungen und ich würde mir
wünschen dass das auch in die
entscheidungen der ministerpräsidenten
runde eingang findet aber im moment wo
wir auf diese dritte welle zu steuern
und hohe infektionszahlen prognostiziert
werden da würden sie sagen das ist nicht
dem würde jetzt nicht trauen das srk
jeder so sagt die diskussion ist doch
schon dort entstanden bei der frage
müssen wir uns weiterhin nur am
incidents wert orientieren sollten wir
nicht auf auch die auslastung der
intensivstation schauen auf die
todeszahlen auf die frage wie viele
menschen in deutschland sind bereits
geimpft unser
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen sagt
selbst die todeszahlen bei den über
80-jährigen nimmt rapide ab das sind
doch erkenntnisse aus den entscheidungen
folgen müssen aus denen durch eine eine
schlussfolgerung entstehen das hieße
ihre schlussfolgerung einfach mehr
lockern also nicht so streng nicht zum
beispiel nicht diese oster ruhe machen
ganz konkret selbstverständlich ein
abwägungsprozess zu treffen
zu überlegen wie viel freiheit können
wir den menschen einräumen ja und wie
viel einschränkungen müssen wir zwingend
in ihm und vor allem wie sinnvoll ist
das okay also eher streiter sie haben
angst vor ein paar wochen gesagt die
einfachste botschaft müsste eigentlich
lauten hört auf die kanzlerin wenn es um
die pandemie in die kanzlerin die immer
eigentlich für strengere maßnahmen war
anders als forscher jetzt beschreibt die
einfach eigentlich viel härteren lockte
er schon im oktober wollte gilt ihr satz
noch hört auf die kanzlerin kann man
noch auf die kanzlerin hören wenn sie
sich am nächsten tag korrigieren muss
gut es müssen sie jetzt nicht alle
entschuldigen
also insofern muss man ja da muss man
jetzt nicht aus gehören wobei es auch
mal es wäre auch für die politische
kultur gar nicht schlecht wenn sich erst
einmal leute wenn sie mal für einen
irrtum einräumen würden
also ich persönlich sehe das ganz anders
als herr schenke ich bin aber auch kein
politiker ich bin der meinung es hat
funktioniert halt immer noch nicht dass
wir das virus einfach einengen wir
können das nur bekämpfen indem wir uns
weniger bewegen und das war jetzt der
versuch mit dieser komischen oper die
quatsch war das muss man anders angehen
also ich würde ich würde gerne in
deutschland mal 14 tage lang in camping
oder abschicken dass wir alle zu hause
bleiben kein bus keine bahn nicht fährt
und das würden wir auch ertragen weil
wir dann auch irgendwie hinterher messen
könnten ob es funktioniert hat oder
nicht
unabhängig davon finde ich es ist jetzt
einfach so dass man wenn man das andere
nicht schafft wenn man sich nicht dazu
durchringen sozusagen zu einem totalen
lockt da und muss man eben die einzige
möglichkeit nutzen die man noch hat das
ist impfen so empfinden und zwar völlig
unabhängig davon wie alt jemand ist aber
jetzt dran ist oder nicht dass man
einfach alles weg was da ja das ist ja
die frage ist aber jetzt über die wir
jetzt ja noch mal sprechen wollten die
frage des vertrauens der bevölkerung in
die maßnahmen
sie sagen sie kriegen viel negatives
negatives feedback frauchen leute sind
verärgert frustriert weil sachen nicht
klar kommuniziert sind frau klaus in
bayern sind die zahlen ja auch immer
noch hoch aber man hat diesen
ministerpräsident der den das image hat
er greift richtig durch passt das
eigentlich ist das was er nach außen hin
darstellt passt das eigentlich über ein
mit dem erfolg den er dann auch hat also
man kann es ja langsam nicht mehr hören
wie markus söder sich ständig selbst
lebt heute in seiner regierungserklärung
oder in seiner rede im landtag hat er
auch wieder gesagt bayern steht jetzt an
platz 6 der instanz zahlen also nicht
mehr an platz eins war also das sieht ja
jetzt als erfolg weil im sommer letzten
jahres da gab es in bayern und in
nordrhein-westfalen die höchsten
instanzen und todesraten und jetzt steht
bayern offenbar auf platz setzt also
eher er wird nicht müde immer ständig
darauf hinzuweisen
wie gut sich bayern seine meinung sagen
nach doch präsentiert also er ist also
wirklich der klassen streber der sich
halt wirklich am meisten über die
einzigen zeugnisse freut man die anderen
nur dreien haben ich glaube das macht
ihn auch nicht wirklich sympathischer er
kommt doch keiner habe ich selber nicht
erklären warum es sich das selber immer
so loben muss ja wir haben im sommer er
diese tests ja aber ich bin gespannt auf
die nächste umfrage die glaube ich
nächste woche raus kommt heute ist ja
eine umfrage rausgekommen die besagt
dass die union nur noch bei 26 prozent
ist und die grünen bei 22 prozent
also da segelt ja die union gerade
direkt in richtung oppositionsbank
und egal wer nachher das steuer führt
markus söder oder armin laschet keiner
von beiden kann sich sicher sein dass er
am ende als bundeskanzler
da steht dann noch vor einem halben jahr
auch undenkbar da hat man gedacht die
die union könne ein besenstiel
aufstellen und würde gewinnen
ok ich glaube das ist ja auch genau das
was die union gerade irgendwie sehr
besorgt frau stimmte wie sehr merken sie
die unruhe in ihrer partei dass es eben
seit diesen landtagswahlen und seitdem
ende auch seeed die umfragen sind
schlecht dass es nicht mehr so
selbstverständlich ist dass der nächste
kanzler von der union kommen
die unruhe ist dahingehend natürlich
groß also wir haben natürlich die offene
frage wer wird ist letztendlich aber die
noch viel entscheidendere frage finde
ich ist die mit welchen inhalten gehen
wir in die zukunft und ich finde das
kann man jetzt auch entscheiden mag man
kann auch jetzt die kanzlerfrage
entscheiden und man kann auch jetzt das
programm festlegen weil ein kandidat der
jetzt antritt muss nicht über das jetzt
und hier sprechen der redet über die
zukunft und wir werden genug zu tun
haben nach dem september nach corona
nach einer langen merke lehrer und da
liegt eigentlich der ball auf dem
elfmeterpunkt wir haben es mit
interessanten politischen mitbewerbern
zu tun und ich verstehe gar nicht warum
unsere beiden protagonisten sich da also
nicht aus der deckung trauen und dann
sagen wir mal konkret direkt in hätten
wieder gerne ich will die frage
eigentlich offen lassen weil ich weil
ich kann nein ich will sie offen lassen
weil ich beiden diese aufgabe zutraue
ich spüre natürlich schon auch bei uns
in den neuen
bundesländern dass so ein typ wie markus
söder gut ankommt weil der körper zu den
macher aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
gerade wenn ich mir diesen auftritt von
armin laschet heute auch im landtag in
nordrhein-westfalen anschaut der kann
das natürlich auch für mich ist
entscheidend für unsere wähler ist
entscheidend was für ein programm steht
dahinter kommen wir mal zu den inhalt
bleiben wir noch ein bisschen bei den
bei den personen herrkoerper wie sehr
will armin laschet kanzlerkandidat
werden
das hat sich ja klar committed er hat
sich geprüft in den vergangenen monaten
bevor daneben sie in parteichef wurde
von mit dieser wahl steht ist es ist
klar dass ein wenn der chef das ich
gesagt hat ich möchte gerne kanzler kann
gehört werden ich möchte da auch
bundeskanzler werden weiters ist ja
sozusagen also ein cdu chef der diesmal
an stoff mich hat der ist wahrscheinlich
längste zeit cdu-chef letztendlich
gewesen
ich würde wahrscheinlich ein stück weit
wieder sprechen und dass man sagen wir
müssten jetzt schnell diese lösungen
finden wir müssen ein paar kamen über
die zukunft sprechen
ich glaube die leute wollen von armina
stellt und auch von markus söder genauso
wie von angela merkel momentan eher wenn
jemand das aktuell die probleme gelöst
haben gerade gehört impfen
dazu gehört ja noch testen bzw wenn
armin darstellt jetzt groß über die
zukunftsweisende projekte spricht an
einem tag wo die regierung einen
rückwärtssalto und hingelegt hat dann
kam mir das etwas schräg und handys
steht flasche dann stück weit in ein
dilemma dass er ja das ist ja selber
definiert zwischen ostern und pfingsten
ist der kanzlerkandidatenfrage erklären
werden wenn wir das mal auf die
prognosen hinsichtlich der dritten welle
liegen dann ist es genau anfang mitte
april wo diese welle so sagen es
zumindest mit ihrer weit nach oben geht
und wenn armin laschet dann in dieser
phase sich selbst zum kanzlerkandidaten
ausrufen möchte dann dann wirkt das auch
so als kümmern als ich gerade richtig
und das land und dahinter ist es ja
meine cdu so dass sie gerade eine
doppelte krise erlebt dass der einen
seite die masten affäre zähler auf der
habenseite an dem ihr und das ganze
korrigiert in den salons weiß dass das
hauptprogramm der cdu oder der union
hauptsächlich gut zu regieren und das
kriegt was das ist gerade nicht läuft
gerade nicht so gut herrscht reiter ist
derjenige dann letztendlich der wirt
oder wird derjenige kanzlerkandidat der
im moment der das land am besten durch
die krise führt also probe die zahlen am
niedrigsten in nordrhein westfalen oder
bayern ist das letztendlich dann
ausschlaggebend
also ich würde das nicht auf einen
wettbewerb zwischen nordrhein-westfalen
und bayern reduzieren sondern es geht
einfach darum wer verein die union
hinter sich und natürlich hat die hat
die cdu innerhalb der union den anspruch
den kanzlerkandidaten zu stellen einfach
weil ich die große partei ist und weil
die macht hat und sie würde natürlich
immer nur markus söder fragen wenn sie
den eindruck hat der eigene mann oder
die eigene frau bringt nicht genug
stimmen und da brauchen wir noch eine
große lokomotive vorneweg
das hauptproblem ist einfach dass die
ziel dass die union jetzt insgesamt die
ist jetzt einfach an einem tiefpunkt
angelangt so und die das jahr hat so
schrecklich für sie begonnen wie man
sich in den schlimmsten träumen nicht
ausmalen konnte
sie haben die ersten zwei wahlen
krachend verloren und zwar schlimmer als
befürchtet
und jetzt haben sie ein problem mit
corona so und da kann ich wenn ich jetzt
die cdu beraten würde würde ich sagen es
gibt jetzt nur zwei dinge die er tun
muss ihr müsst einmal die korona politik
stabilisieren also mit mit einer mit dem
mit dem eindruck einer versagen der
regierung eine wahl gehen zu wollen das
ist sehr schwierig ja so und das andere
ist ich muss natürlich muss auch die cdu
muss jetzt natürlich sichtbar beginnen
sich von angela merkel zu lösen
ja und das muss ein mann machen wie
armin laschet der ja also ich kann man
auch wie er aus dem rheinland man muss
das eben so hinkriegen dass niemand
beschädigt ist ja also es hat jetzt
keinen sinn zu sagen angela merkel hat
alles falsch gemacht was machen wir
künftig alles anders sondern
aber jetzt sagt klaus haben das glaube
ich vorhin gesagt dass jetzt durch diese
diese diesen auftritt von merkel wo sich
gesagt hat ich nehme die ganze schuld
sozusagen auf mich dass sie dadurch
eigentlich nochmal sich die ordnung
wiederhergestellt hat dass sie wieder
die macherin ist frau schimke können die
anderen denn wirklich ist also sehen sie
das auch so
nein nein das sehe ich nicht so ich
glaube das ist eine geste der fairness
gewesen
ich kann nicht sagen wie die
verhandlungen im detail gelaufen sind
ich war ja nicht dabei aber ich glaube
es ist eine geste der fairness gegenüber
den anderen beteiligten und den schaden
zu minimieren der entstanden ist aber
noch mal ich würde trotzdem darauf
hinweist und da unterscheide ich mich in
der tat von der auffassung von herrn
kopper wir müssen uns lösen von dem
gedanken dass wir im schlafwagen in das
kanzleramt fahren das wird nicht
passieren
wir müssen uns zwangsläufig von der
regierung emanzipieren das ist so wir
können nicht weitermachen wie bisher die
menschen wollen andere antworten auf
andere probleme in diesem land die
korona krise hat uns brutal vor augen
geführt wo wir bei der digitalisierung
stehen wo wir bei der bildung stehen wo
wir bei der wenn sie so wollen bei der
inneren sicherheit gesehen wir schon
seit 2015 die polizei ist überlastet die
justiz ist überlasse wir haben einen
riesigen berg an problemen an
strukturellen probleme in diesem land zu
bewältigen
und obwohl die letzten jahre sehr gut
und erfolgreich waren mit angela merkel
müssen wir als cdu uns neu aufstellen
inhaltlich unperson aber wem greifen sie
denn all diese probleme an und diese
fehler und dieses was alles versäumt
worden ist ich glaube unser unserem land
ging es lange lange zeit sehr sehr gut
und wir haben lange zeit von der
substanz gelebt wir hatten an in den
frühen 2000er jahren unter gerhard
schröder harte reformen in unserem land
gehabt ja auch auf dem arbeitsmarkt
beispielsweise dann kam der
wirtschaftliche aufschwung der wohlstand
rekordbeschäftigung ja die geringste
arbeitslosigkeit aller zeiten hatten wir
und auf dieser grundlage konnte man
natürlich krisen gut bewältigen und ein
stück weit auch für ruhe sorgen aber
inzwischen bricht das hoch wir haben
glaube ich auch in den vielen jahren
viele viele hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
und uns einfach auf dem wohlstand auf
dem status wo wir waren ausgeruht ja die
frage ist einfach ein bisschen
beweglicher werden ja wer ist denn dann
da beweglicher vor klaus wenn sie aus
bayern dann mal nach nordrhein westfalen
was würden sie denn sagen ist laschet
jemand der das hinkriegt und hat der
dann ist das dann doch eben ein
unterschied wenn jemand aus der un- aus
der cdu kommt und dass es eben immer
noch so merkwürdig ist dass ein bayer
ganz deutschland regieren soll dass es
spielt ja irgendwie immer noch eine
rolle also zunächst ich habe schon das
gefühl armin laschet ist der fels in der
brandung und markus söder ist die
brandung oder wo im in bildform vom
schlafwagen zu bleiben armin laschet
sitzt im schlafwagen und markus söder
vorn in der lokomotive also jedenfalls
machte hielt er sich auch gerne wären ja
durchaus aber er hat ja auch am sonntag
habe ich um sieben uhr morgens eine
presse einladung bekommen
zur transparenz offensive in der union
darüber haben wir noch gar nicht geredet
das problem ist ja nicht nur das die
union gerade die korona krise nicht
geregelt bekommt sondern sie scheint ja
auch ihren moralischen kompass zu
verlieren also desaströser kann das bild
ja gar nicht sein kein impfstoff keine
selbsttests keine moralischen kompass
kein parteiprogramm und kein
spitzenkandidat man wundert sich ja fast
warum die union überhaupt auf 26 prozent
kommt also und ebenso frau schimke hat
da schon recht es braucht eigentlich
jemand der mal ein alternativangebot zur
kanzlerin macht ich bleib dabei angela
merkel hat jetzt sich taktisch glaube
ich ganz klug verhalten indem sie ihren
kopf hingehalten hat und jetzt also
platz macht für ideen aus der union für
markus söder spricht ja von einer neuen
csu von einem zukunftsteam das jetzt
alternativen anbietet und söder bietet
ständig anja spricht in jede
fernsehkamera und armin laschet ist ein
bisschen selektiver unterwegs er
strahlte wie glaubwürdig ist dass diese
transparenz offensive die jetzt davon
süder kommt und wie sehr schade die
ganze masken affären
die schalt unheimlich aber es ist eben
nur der eindruck von einer moralischen
verfehlung herumreichen inkompetenz ist
ja wirklich mal ist in vier oder fünf
von hundert abgeordneten
ich finde das auch ganz schrecklich und
diese leute haben der union unendlich
also haben wir mindestens genauso
gescheitert wie diese ganzen kroner
politik das ganze den ganzen probleme
und so die ganzen schwierigkeiten also
das ist wirklich weil das die leute
natürlich die leute nehmen das ja
kombiniert war ja sie sagen auf der
einen seite es funktioniert nicht alles
oder es funktioniert nicht wie nachdem
wo man steht und dann sind machen die
auch noch geschäfte ja das ist natürlich
also schlimmer kann es gar nicht kommen
und da ist halt ganz schwer raus zu
kommen und ich meine ich fand ich werde
das am sonntag hat mich genauso
überrascht und ich fand das aber richtig
meint wir müssen dann nur auch das tun
was sie ankündigen
aber die csu ist nun eine partei die so
eng und die immer ring regiert hat in
bayern diese info boden ist mit der
wirtschaft das ist ja wirklich ne also
egal wo man denkt ja die müssen sich ja
völlig neu erfinden eigentlich ja zum
einen namen auftauchen diverser manche
ja schon längst vergessen haben also
kandler und solche sachen also und und
es ist ja auch irgendwie offenbar ein
tiefes geflecht also die müssen sich
wirklich neu erfinden und das wird nicht
unproblematisch seien auch innerhalb der
csu aber das traue ich schon zu dass er
das irgendwie hinkriegt und weil so ein
einzelerfolg und dann ist eben auch
völlig egal wer da hinten runterfällt
na ja gerade wenn man wieder armin
laschet und markus söder vergleicht
armin laschet hat ja da in dieser
hinsicht selber so ein bisschen ein
problem in der familie dass das sein
sohn da angeblich lobbyiert hat für van
laak und und masken irgendwie im
schnellverfahren an die nrw regierung
mit vermittelt hat und das freut glaube
ich insgeheim markus söder der ja schon
immer das image des saubermanns hatte
und schon immer gesagt hat also die csu
sei die partei der in leverkusen
er selbst macht sich überhaupt nicht
ausreichten ich glaube er versucht da
sich zu profilieren gegen armin laschet
körper spielt das noch eine rolle weil
bei dieser geschichte mit von lag
dagegen ist ja kein geld geflossen da
ging es ja um eine kontakt herstellung
das ist glaube ich etwas anders wurde
etwas anders bewertet als das was der
nutzer ein und gemacht hat ich würde das
auch anders bewerten dass in der stelle
nicht miteinander vergleichen aber
nichtsdestotrotz diese vergleiche kommen
und die menschen sehen dass man sonst
auch immer wieder in der
berichterstattung mit auf insofern gab
ist das ein problem
wir haben am vergangenen wochenende weil
es angesprochen wäre da noch einmal die
unterschiede zwischen diesen beiden
politiker typen gesehen haben laschet
und markus söder während markus söder
hat immer sehr offensiv transparenz
pressekonferenz nicht statt konto man
müsste sich entscheiden einfache
botschaften setzt ist armin darstellt
ein ganz anderer typ muss er ist eben
nicht dieser kannte der krisenmanager
sondern erwirbt dann eher in die
parteien versuchen alle mitzunehmen
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher auf das
was ich so höre ist ja dieser masten
affäre waren ich mich untätig gewesen
sondern hat versuchen dort einiges
anzuschieben
nichtsdestotrotz ist ja eben nicht
dieser verkäufer typ nach außen dieser
krisenmanager den es aber vielleicht in
einer krise und sie haben bisher galt
eben auch schon gesagt wir sprechen hier
die ganze zeit sondern der doppelten
krise und nach einen seite auf der
anderen seite versuchen die menschen
orientierung da braucht es vielleicht
einfache parolen wenn dir auch ich weiß
es nicht frau klaus kann das besser
beurteilen unfall von markus felder
nicht immer gedeckt sind
nichtsdestotrotz die simulation von
führung ist vielleicht in dieser phase
auch schon an wert
so könnte ich mir auch vorstellen man
merkt auch bei den pressekonferenzen von
nach der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
dass söder sätze spricht die man sich
merkt die sind das ist einfacher und die
kanzlerin mit vielen zahlen hantiert und
wo man denkt ist sie diejenige die uns
durch die krise führt frau stimmt wenn
man jetzt mal auf die inhalte schauen
sie sagen wir haben so viele
versäumnisse auf allen möglichen ebenen
und so viel probleme in diesem land was
würden sie sagen ist das wichtigste dass
ein kanzlerkandidat sagen müsste wofür
er steht wo man auch weiß dass krieg ich
vor allen dingen bei der union da weiß
ich dafür steht die union gut die union
hat natürlich ganz
stimmte kompetenz themen dazu zählt die
innere sicherheit dazu zählt die
wirtschafts- und arbeitsmarktpolitik
aber dazu zählt genauso gut auch
sozialpolitik und bildungspolitik also
ich glaube wir können uns jetzt nicht
nicht beschränken sage ich mal auf auf
23 themen sondern wir und dass das ist
eben halt auch bestandteil von politik
von heute und anspruch einer volkspartei
wir müssen in allen themen spreche sein
und ganz ehrlich das sind alles nur
menschen auch in kanzlerkandidat und
auch eine angela merkel hat mal auf
einer ganz anderen ebene angefangen und
sie ist zudem gemacht worden was sie
heute ist und ich habe das vertrauen und
ich habe die überzeugung dass das mit
jedem kandidaten er jetzt antritt auch
gelänge lücken zu fliehen es ist völlig
egal wer antritt so steht das
entscheidende ist bei dem auf dem die
partei sich verständigt dass sie hinter
ihm steht die truppe muss motiviert
werden wir brauchen motivierte aktive
fröhliche wahlkämpfer vor ort relativ
knapp zum chef der union geworden also
ist er dann dann der richtige
er genießt unser vertrauen wir hätten
uns gerade auch als mittelstands union
gerne einen anderen gewünscht friedrich
merz armin laschet ist es geworden aber
wir sind eine faire und loyale partei
und dazu zählt eben auch dass wir den
der es geworden ist unterstützen nach
kräften
wir erwarten aber auch dass er uns
einbindet dass er uns mitnimmt als
partei als mittelstands union ja dass er
alle flügel und das ist das wofür armin
laschet immer geworben hat zusammen mit
dem ok und könnte so dass auch herr
streiter was denken sie aus ihrer
beobachtung auch der vielen jahre die
sie die union kennen was für ein typ
braucht die union die mit angela merkel
auch teilweise ja doch länger gefremdelt
hat gerade die westdeutsche union
naja sie braucht jemanden der wie vor
chemischen sagte der diesen ganzen sack
flöhe in irgendeiner weise zusammen hält
es gibt natürlich an die union ist ja
sehr groß und da gibt es halt die
unterschiedlichen interessen und die
muss man halt irgendwie alle unter einen
hut kriegen und zwar im konsens und
nicht in der auseinandersetzung und das
war ja auch das was in völlig märz und
armin laschet sehr unterschieden hat
also fröhlich märz ist halt mehr der typ
kopf durch die wand
während amri laschet mehr so der
menschenfänger ist oder er versucht es
jedenfalls zu sein
und also ich glaube er ist für die union
insgesamt etwas geeigneter weil er weil
er halt sehr flexibel ist ja markus
söder ist jetzt neuerdings auch sehr
flexibel aber der abwehr zu flexibel ja
also jemand der so plötzlich anfängt die
bienen zu streicheln und bäume zu
umarmen
also das klappt man ihm dann irgendwann
nicht mehr weil man das finnische hält
und da muss ja auch ein bisschen
aufpassen
aber wie auch immer die union braucht
jemanden auch der also jetzt
parteiintern der ein bisschen das herz
streichelt ja denn die seele streichelt
der überall da ist und auch mal hinkommt
und zugänglich ist und mit normalen
menschen umgehen kann und nicht immer
auf dem regierungsschiff obenauf wissen
wofür die union dann stehen frau klaus
was würden sie sagen wo würde mit seinen
klaren botschaften ist es jemand der das
schafft der hat ja eine hohe
zustimmungswerte auch und auch wenn es
der union in den umfragen es schlechter
geht aber wenn man jetzt nach personen
geht dann liegt er immer vorne also
woran was ist da sein geheimnis wo sagen
sie woher kriegt das hin dass er auch
dann zum beispiel die bäume umarmt und
die bienen streichelt und die leute
nehmen
also er führt die umfragen ja nicht nur
knapp an also er hat ja doppelt so viel
zustimmung wie armin laschet das finde
ich schon beachtlich aber das sind um
fragen die nicht bei parteifunktionären
gemacht werden sondern bei den bürgern
und das sind zwei unterschiedliche dinge
also ich habe schon den eindruck dass
die union wenn sie wirklich die wahl
gewinnen will
mit markus söder von den umfragen her
die die besseren chancen hat einfach
weil die bürger ihnen plötzlich mehr
vertrauen
da war ja immer der mann dem die
menschen alles zutrauen aber nicht
vertrauen das hat sich jetzt geändert
das ist dieser aktionismus das sind
diese pressekonferenzen am sonntag dass
es dieses dass er letzte woche
angekündigt hat na gut wir haben keinen
impfstoff aber was soll's wir bestellen
jetzt den sputnik impfstoff und den
lassen wir sogar in bayern herstellen
absoluter ist super viel aktionismus mit
buy aber er vermittelt den eindruck ich
will was ich mach was ich tue das
menschenmögliche und armin laschet ist
die integrierende hre figur die
beliebtere figur absolut ich habe ihr
leben in der gleichen partei
doch als interpretin die ökopartei
beliebte aber nicht bei den bürgern erst
bei vielen bürgern hier in bayern
jedenfalls noch nicht mal bekannt
markus söder hingegen ist jedem ein
begriff das ist ein unschätzbarer
vorteil in einer zeit in der wahlkampf
nicht vor ort bei den leuten passieren
wird sondern im internet und vor
fernsehkameras passieren wird weil wir
können uns ja leider nach wie vor nicht
persönlich in die augen schauen und mit
den anderen rechtlich leider frau
stimmte wie wichtig ist es dass diese
entscheidung jetzt schnell getroffen
wird zwischen ostern und pfingsten das
sind 50 tage aber wie schnell muss das
jetzt sein
also ich finde diese entscheidung sollte
jetzt zügig getroffen werden wir haben
ja auch noch ein bisschen wahlkampf vor
uns dann nicht dass man so anmerken darf
und wir brauchen auch noch zeit um mit
unserem programm und mit unserem
kandidaten zu werben das braucht ja auch
sagen es kann nicht mein programm habe
ich dann jedoch fünf vor zwölf um die
ecke kommen und sagen so und das wäre es
jetzt
sondern ich muss ja ein bisschen
programm auch mit anbieten und das
braucht etwas zeit so und deswegen bin
ich dafür jetzt diese entscheidung
endlich zu treffen die herren hatten
auch echt genug zeit sich darüber zu
verständigen treiber herrkoerper müsste
jetzt herr laschet sein der sagt so was
weiß ich eine woche nach ostern nach der
oster ruhe jetzt komme ich raus und sag
jetzt mal wäre es wird wer muss wen beim
frühstück besuchen sozusagen wie früher
wie
damals angela merkel beim frühstück in
wolfratshausen herrn stoiber besucht hat
naja es ist ziemlich klar dass der cdu
selbst sozusagen das heft des handelns
in der hand das haben wir beide auch da
gemacht markus söder hat das ja auch
sozusagen akzeptiert wenn markus wieder
einmal was akzeptiert wo die sich
letztendlich treffen
das ist schwer zu sagen das wird viel
beachtet sein es geht glaube ich auch
eher in richtung ostern als zum bericht
um pfingsten jablonki zur wolfratshausen
ist natürlich in der hinsicht nicht ganz
richtig oder voraussetzung ein wenig
anders dass es innerhalb der cdu
meines erachtens momentan niemanden gibt
der wie damals bei angela merkel
aufsteht und sagt sie oder du je nach
treten können das nicht und sie ist
danach aus freien stücken eben nach
wolfratshausen gefahren hat das dem
csu-chef angedient ich glaube die lage
diesbezüglich ist etwas anders ich sehe
in der cdu gerade niemanden vom gewicht
der aufstehen würde aber sagen würde
armin kannst es nicht das musste markus
machen und da stellt sich klar committed
liegt das heft sozusagen bei ihm bei
markus söder wissen wir bis heute nicht
ob er wirklich will
ihre äußerungen mein platz ist in bayern
nach zuletzt zwar nicht mehr gehört wie
kann er sich ja immer noch zurückziehen
insofern wird markus söder sicherlich
auch taxieren wie die chancen liegen
denn eine csu die zu hause große
probleme hat krise z bei dem massaker
gesprochen dass er dann als parteien auf
ein wackeliges surfbrett richtung berlin
geht das sie standen jetzt nicht okay
vielen dank herr körper ich habe gehört
dass sie aus technischen gründen jetzt
das hier verlassen müssen dann würde ich
mal jetzt schön dank sagen gerne bleiben
noch ein bisschen länger bei uns vielen
dank frau klaus wie wie wichtig wäre
dass ein solider dass er sagt ich mache
jetzt hier auch den kandidaten wenn er
wenn die umfragen weiter so schlecht
sind und dass er möglicherweise sein
kann dass er dann nicht ins kanzleramt
kommt oder ist dass jemand tritt nur an
wenn klar ist wer kann auch gewinnen das
ist das ewige dilemma dass markus söder
natürlich ist ein sehr risikoscheu
mensch und er würde am liebsten nur dann
antreten wenn klar wäre er würde auch
gewinnen ja das wäre typisch oder aber
in der vergangenheit haben
csu-kandidaten immer nur dann eine
chance bekommen wenn es kritisch war
fast aussichtslos also eigentlich eine
ziemliche sorgen schon jetzt gerade tag
heute haben also ich glaube markus söder
würde sich die chance nicht entgehen
lassen herzlich schon vor zwei drei
wochen einen kleinen welpen gekauft den
er in die kameras gehalten sein und
seitdem bin ich sicher er will
ok damit er ihn armin laschet lässt das
ok dann hätte man auch mal ein hund im
kanzleramt
wie also noch einmal wie wichtig ist es
dass das jetzt in der mit der korona
pandemie anders läuft oder erfolgreich
läuft und um dann zu sagen dass zahlt
dann auch auf die union ein dann sieht
man wieder da kann das schafft die union
und da ist die die führende partei weil
letztendlich ist es natürlich ein
problem weil die länder natürlich ganz
viel von dieser corona politik auch
mitbestimmen also wenn man wenn man die
regierung stellt und die kanzlerin
stellt dann kann das natürlich auf der
einen seite eine große chance sein das
kann aber auch eine bürde sein
ja wenn es gerade in der regierung nicht
läuft dann haben es natürlich die
wahlkämpfer schwierig insofern ich finde
es wichtig dass wir dieses vakuum also
was entsteht weil wir einfach auch
draußen den leuten nicht sagen können
wie wird es weitergehen mit der cdu das
möchten die menschen von uns wissen was
passiert nach angela merkel dass wir
diese frage beantworten ich glaube aber
dass in dem zusammenhang noch etwas
anderes wichtig ist wir müssen uns lösen
von dieser menge oder one-woman-show
finde ich wir sollten uns als partei der
teamfähigkeit präsentieren das ist auch
das was armin laschet immer wieder auch
von sich behauptet hat und für sich als
stärker herausgestellt hat wir brauchen
ein team von guten von neuen von fitten
köpfen ja die cdu politik präsentieren
künftig in deutschland okay er streite
was würden sie denn der union jetzt
raten wo sagen sie was jetzt in der
korona politik gemacht werden muss auch
nach diesem desaster jetzt am montag wo
armin laschet auch sagt das geht so
nicht weiter mit dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist das vom
punkt wo man sagen kann da kann er jetzt
mal beweisen dass man auf eine andere
art diese politik macht ja ich finde
armin laschet wenn er bundeskanzler
werden will oder kanzlerkandidat sind
nicht mal der muss jetzt auch mal aus
der deckung gehen und
er muss jetzt einfach mal zeigen dass er
es kann und muss jetzt vorschläge machen
und und wenn man jetzt an einen übergang
denken von angela merkel zu einem
nachfolger oder eine nachfolgerin
da muss ich mich ja irgendwie auch mal
ins spiel bringen und da muss ich ja
irgendwie auch mal zeigen dass ich
sozusagen auf augenhöhe bin und das ist
sozusagen ein toller übergang wäre also
ich muss ja irgendwie eine perspektive
auch den wählern aufgeht präsentieren
das sozusagen selbst wenn angela merkel
die nach wie vor unheimlich eine
unheimliche anhängerschaft hat das
danach deutschland nicht untergeht und
das muss der kandidat sind die hotels
über männer gesprochen bei der union
der jeweilige kandidat der muss dann
schon diese perspektive aufzeigen ja
dass es mit ihm anders weiter geht aber
weiter geht aber er hätte jetzt eine
chance wenn man sagen jetzt muss man
muss er zeigen wie es anders geht glaube
da hat ja heute gesagt man muss noch mal
überlegen ob man da sind ihnen nicht
auch öffentlich trippner andere formate
oder all diese dinge also der versuch
das ja auch jetzt sehr könnte sich ja
auch beweisen frau klaus könnt ihr jetzt
ja auch sagen ich hätte auf den tisch
und jetzt jetzt muss das anders werden
mit dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ja er macht ja schon die ganze zeit er
versucht sich als derjenige ins spiel zu
bringen der der ebene versucht was
voranzubringen ja also während armin
laschet eher im hintergrund wirkt das
ist so eine zeit des stillstandes gerade
eine zeit des wartens und die versucht
markus söder zu nutzen indem er
permanent vorschläge macht und mal
schauen wie weiter damit noch kommt frau
schenk und wenn es dann bei der nächsten
bei der bundestagswahl so wäre so wie
die umfragen geht sind dass die union
mit den grünen regieren würde können sie
dann ihre inhalte gut durchsetzte konnte
das dann am besten also das ist immer
eine frage wie man selbst auftritt mit
welchem selbstbewusstsein man in die
verhandlungen reingeht und ich meine wir
können uns an den koalitionspartner
nicht aussuchen gehe ich mal von aus und
man muss ja gucken dass man sich dass
man irgendwie zusammenfinden dass man
zusammenkommt und ganz entscheidend
finde ich ist dass man wirklich auch
für sich eine rote linie hat ja dass man
sagt bis hierhin und nicht weiter ja das
ist das was verlässlichkeit ausmacht
einer partei das vertrauen ausmacht und
das wäre ein dass das ist mein größter
wunsch dass wir das tun in der noch
einmal vor dieser situation stehen mit
dem auch immer war in verhandlungen zu
treten wirklich auch darauf zu achten
dass die dna der cdu sich deutlich
stärker im koalitionsvertrag
wiederfinden eingegangen stadtkurs zum
schluss noch ihr tipp wer wird ganze
reihe an statt zügig weiter nicht
ausschließen ok überhören sie uns noch
da können sie noch sprechen herr laschet
oder ja gerne
ich habe viele gute dinge genannt wurden
diese körperlich oder immer unterstützt
okay das reicht schon wenn am ende der
sendung
das ok also hier drei zu eins für david
also vielen dank ihnen für diese
diskussion morgen reden wir in der
phoenix runde auch wieder über die
pandemie im zickzack durch die pandemie
wie steht deutschland da unter anderem
wolfgang bosbach und boris palmer sind
dann unsere gäste ich freue mich wenn
sie dabei sind bis dahin tschüss